smarter than a beaver and as heroic as
Schwarzenegger nauru from prey has
plenty of amazing moments but which ones
are the best and bravest right away in
the first five minutes of prey we're
given a telling glimpse into the kind of
character nauru will prove herself to be
at the start of the movie nauru's trusty
dog sari gets her tail stuck in a bear
trap not only does this foreshadow later
scenes in which bear traps will appear
in much more dire circumstances It also
says a lot about nauru without any
dialogue At All by Saving her dog the
first thing we get to know about nauru
is her compassion and her utter
fearlessness when a loved one is hurt
despite her struggles with them she
values her family and will protect them
at all costs however this isn't all
there is to the movie's young Comanche
hero she is above all incredibly driven
to prove herself as a hunter despite the
gender Norms of her tribe this drive
will go on to inspire her actions
throughout prey why do you want to hunt
because you all think that I can't
director Dan Trachtenberg and his crew
clearly recognized their obligation to
bring some sweet new gadgets for the
Predator to use and prey delivers
spectacularly on this front however one
of the coolest pieces of tech in the
film is actually developed by nauru
early on into hunting the alien she ties
a rope to her Hatchet in order to be
able to throw and retrieve the weapon
quickly Trachtenberg revealed during an
interview with comicbook.com that he
drew inspiration from the 2018 God of
War video game for this rope ax that
allows nauru to pull off some stylish
kills without ever losing her trusty
weapon it goes on to pay off with a
crucial role in the movie particularly
in the scene when nauru first stumbles
into the quicksand swamp and finds
herself sinking with seemingly little
hope of escape the only way out is to
use the rope ax to latch onto a downed
tree and pull herself up this moment
highlights naru's resourcefulness and
her ability to think on her feet a
unique form of Bravery that will prove
to be important later on
after attacking the Comanche Hunting
Party in the bloody scene prior the
Predator stalks nauru and itsy into the
Tall Grass clearing near the camp hiding
out in the grass eats a an overconfident
hunter in the Comanche tribe spots the
predator and prepares his bow thinking
that he and nauru have the upper hand
no he has us nauru saves itsei from
being shot but as the two run away itsei
is caught by the predator and dies in
one of the most brutal deaths prey has
to offer this moment illustrates that
although she hasn't gotten the chance to
prove herself nauru truly is a skilled
Hunter who uses her instincts to assess
any kind of situation she has the wisdom
to recognize that choosing what keeps
you alive in a long Battle of attrition
with a foe like the Predator is always
the correct choice
after the Predator's assault on the
French Trapper's Camp nauru returns to
retrieve sorry but she's surprised to
find that one of the men still clings to
life the Survivor turns out to be the
group's translator Raphael he begs Naru
to heal him before he bleeds out however
taking advantage of her position of
power she will only do it if Raphael
teaches her how to use his flintlock
pistol barely clinging to life the
translator has no choice but to agree to
her terms after demonstrating how it
works he gives her the flintlock and
nauru gives him medicinal herbs to treat
his bleeding wound after she uses the
herbs on Raphael the Predator returns
allowing Naru to discover a hidden
property of her medicine the Predator
can't see Raphael due to the medicine
reducing his body heat and that's when
Naru realizes that its vision is based
on heat signatures this moment is of
course a big reference to the original
Predator echoing the scene in which
Arnold Schwarzenegger's Dutch discovers
that the Predator can't see him when
he's covered in mud as sharp as she may
be nauru really rides the line between
being brave and being an idiot it when
she decides to leave the camp without
telling anyone where she's headed in
Pursuit Of The Predator nauru is getting
in way over her head ultimately though
this proves to be an act of Bravery
instead of foolishness and ending up as
a real turning point in prey Naru needs
to embark on her cutthamiya a rite of
passage that all Hunters must undergo in
order to prove themselves to the tribe
the details of this ritual are important
since they require the hunter to hunt an
animal that can also hunt them a
predator nauru realizes before everyone
else that the alien interloper is a
hunter and she accepts his arrival as a
sign it's her time to be tested the
moment she decides to go out on her own
without anyone's help nauru commits to
making this her kathamia and that drive
to prove herself to everyone inspires
her for the rest of the movie
at the end of the movie nauru gets to
complete her Arc in a triumphant finale
as she returns from the hunt victorious
she comes back to the camp covered in
neon green Predator blood with the head
of her prey held in her hands it's the
most empowering moment nauru gets in the
whole movie bringing her character full
circle as the community gathers around
her she tosses the head at the feet of
the tribe's leader to accept her
rightful place as a Comanche Warrior
this isn't merely nauru coming back from
her katamia regularly a cause for
celebration but her returning as the
savior of her tribe having killed the
creature that took her brother and most
of the male Hunters nauru has made her
way to the top of the food chain in a
short matter of time with most of the
Hunter's dead Naru Remains the singular
defense the tribe has
after they're both independently
captured by the French Trappers nauru
and tabe are tied up to a tree together
and used as bait for the Predator but
since the Predator only hunts humans and
animals who pose a threat to it it
ignores the captives and goes straight
for the armed trappers who are waiting
in the wings to attack amid the chaos
nauru thinks on her feet to figure out
how to free herself in tabe from their
ropes upon seeing the bear trap on the
ground near their restraints nauru
figures out how she can use it to cut
their ropes Trachtenberg uses this
opportunity to trick the viewer as nauru
begins telling tabe a story about how a
beaver will escape from traps by chewing
its own leg off tabe begins to panic
thinking his sister is about to
sacrifice her limb for their freedom but
as we've learned nauru always thinks
past the obvious answer to find a better
one another stop
oh
I'm smarter than a beaver one of the
most brutal moments in prey doesn't even
need a predator around to set off a
flurry of violence instead in a moment
showing the parallels between our young
hero and the movie's young Predator
nauru is the instigator of this assault
when sneaking up on the Trapper Camp she
sees that they have captured sorry and
intend to harm him when she Springs into
action Naru is quick and deadly using
her assailants weapons against them as
well as her own rope acts she swiftly
puts an end to the remaining Trappers
it's the moment that shows the most
violent side of her but it is crucial to
proving that she's ready to take on the
Predator only now that as she matches
the efficiency bravery and brutality of
her prey can she understand how to take
it down
according to The Escapist one of the
elements of the original Predator that
Dan Trachtenberg picked up and Amplified
in prey is its commentary on colonialism
the anti-colonial themes are summed up
in the antagonistic relationship between
the Comanche and the French Trappers the
movie becomes as much about nauru facing
off against them as it does about her
hunt for the predator in the end the
final Trapper's fate is the most brutal
of all of them but the elaborate plan
that Naru uses to kill two birds with
one stone shines as one of her bravest
moments you can't see
but I'm killing you after we see Naru
sneaking up on the Trapper we see that
she has tied him up in an elaborate
setup to lure the Predator out she cut
off his leg below the knee bleeding him
in order to attract the alien while
hiding herself to its gaze using the
medicinal herbs needless to say it's
incredibly dangerous to attract a
predator to you but this is the type of
Bravery Naru needs as a hunter to
complete her right of passage at the end
of parade Naru gets to put her bravery
to the test in one final Face-Off with
The Predator after luring her prey into
the Frenchman baited trap Naru begins to
use her wits and tools to prove herself
as the true Predator the first and most
important part of the plan is to shoot
the Predator point blank in the head not
only does this strategy inflict a major
head wound to her foe but it ends up
being crucial to how the fight plays out
when nauru shoots the Predator with the
flintlock his mask flies off earlier
nauru had observed that this mask
controls the targeting on the Predator's
spear gun she knows he is weaker without
it so she cleverly uses the element of
surprise to seriously handicap her enemy
as you watch prey it becomes clear that
many moments of nauru's final fight have
been plotted out in advance but one of
the best scenes in the sequence comes
when she's forced to improvise near the
swamp trap Naru is forced between two
rocks by the Predator with its Shield
coming down slowly threatening to
decapitate her with the Predator bearing
down on her nauru grabs a hold of the
mandible horn coming out from its mouth
area she uses it to stab the predator in
the face and takes advantage of the
moment when the Beast cries out in pain
to flee it's a small beat in the middle
of this awesome fight but it stands out
due to its sheer brutality
the elaborate and ingenious trap that
nauru sets up to finally take down the
Predator is definitely the coolest
moment in prey the film keeps you on
your toes throughout the entire
climactic battle only to reveal at the
moment of the final kill that nauru has
had everything in the bag the whole time
from the start of the sequence when
she's hunting the Trapper nauru has been
setting her plan into motion immediately
after she took the shot she grabbed the
mask so she could later put it in its
strategic place in the tree near the
swamp when she finally lures the
Predator into the swamp she has the
mask's targeting lasers aimed right at
it when it attempts to fire its Spears
at nauru the projectiles Miss and hone
in on the Predator instead killing it
immediately in her Victorious moment
Naru reminds us that killing the
Predator was never about Firepower it
was about embracing the traits of a good
Hunter Haitians cunning and bravery all
help Naru defeat the Predator with its
own equipment
[Music]